[A SWOOSHING SOUND]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Selfies--
we're obsessed with them.
I thought I'd seen them all,
until I came across this one--
the orange jumpsuit,
the space helmet,
and the rocket-like capsule.
But how exactly
did this guy manage
to take a photo of himself
on the edge of space?
His selfie game is
on another level.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine looking out the
window and seeing this view.
That's what this man was
lucky enough to witness.
CHRISTOPHER MICHEL: Hi, my
name is Christopher Michel.
I'm from San
Francisco, Californian,
and I'm a photographer.
This photo was taken by me
above northern California
in the backseat of U-2 spy
plane with a GoPro camera.
NARRATOR: U-2 spy planes
have been in service
since the 1950s, which is a
testament to the aircraft's
designer, Kelly Johnson.
Christopher got his
opportunity to fly one
while reporting for
the US Naval Institute
on Johnson and the
aircraft he designed.
Christopher's pilot that day
was Lieutenant Colonel Joe
Santucci.
Before takeoff, both men went
through lengthy medical exams
and had their suits
pressure tested
to ensure that their
core temperatures didn't
rise too quickly.
Christopher was nervous
about the flight,
but he didn't realize
how unique the scene was
going to be until he took off.
[MUSIC PLAYING AND SOUND OF
PLANE TAKING OFF]
CHRISTOPHER MICHEL:
It was really
one of the very best
experiences of my life--
unusual to the extent
that I'm wearing
a spacesuit, unusual to the
extent that the airplane was
followed by [? Camaro ?] on
the runway giving commands
to the pilot,
unusual to the extent
that half the landing gear drops
away at takeoff to save weight.
I never felt sick.
I only felt wonder as the
airplane lifted nose-up,
and we went straight
up to 70,000 feet.
NARRATOR: At that
altitude, temperatures
can drop to 70 below
[? zero. ?] Christopher
noticed that the
glass in the cockpit
was starting to freeze over.
But luckily, the ice
didn't block the view.
CHRISTOPHER MICHEL: A
highlight of the flight
for me was when Joe Santucci
suggested that we turn off
air traffic control-- or
at least turn it down--
and it got very quiet
in the aircraft.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Really, in the spacesuit,
it was definitely quiet.
And I could look up to
the blackness of sky
and down to the blue,
curved Earth below
and really have a moment
of wonder and awe.
NARRATOR: All too
soon, it was time
to come back down to Earth,
which with a U-2 spy plane
is a bit of a daunting prospect.
It takes a skilled
pilot like Santucci
to land the U-2, which has
to stall over the runway
before it touches down.
CHRISTOPHER MICHEL:
The Air Force,
like the pros that they
are, met us with champagne
to congratulate having
reached that altitude.
But I realized that one of the
best moments of my entire life
had just come to an end.
It probably was my
astronaut moment,
although I wasn't an astronaut.
And it's probably going to
be as close as I'll ever get.
NARRATOR: This series is all
about sharing compelling photos
and the stories behind them.
Catch more of "This
Happened Here"
on "Seeker Stories" every
week, and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]